farting and walking away the profoundly
handicapped used panties historically
black colleges crippling debt pac-man
uncontrollably that's Mukesh this is for
horrible people pick your company wisely
when you play this game oh my goodness
we now need to choose whoever starts off
as the car is there the cards are is the
judge then yes the rules specified this
is to be the person who is most recently
gone to the bathroom I just peed before
I came in here all right well then you
can start us off draw 1-1 Andrey it
allows why am I sticky that's what it
actually wow isn't that way why am I
sticky you can't look at them as they
come in this isn't how it goes why am I
sticky daddy issues I like that why am I
sticky it lasts longer than four hours
pretty good why am I sticky mr. clean
right behind you errands why my sticky
pedophiles and the winner is the last
one without a doubt yeah you know it
baby cuz it's true why my sticky
extremely tight pants
yeah that would be yours Matt yeah just
rub down these eight guys own the
company equally they met in the public
school system I said Chicago as nerds
and geeks who would make games for each
other and these guys make a lot a lot of
money